I'm gonna talk about 14 amazing benefits
of oregano oil and this is one of the
reasons why Italians really get sick
because they use a lot of oregano oil on
their their pasta and their pizza and
I'm just being sarcastic the type of
oregano that you want for therapeutic
benefits is the wild oregano oil they
take 200 pounds of oregano the leaves
and the stems and they will concentrate
it into two pounds of this oil and it
has three very powerful phenols or
federal chemicals that are have
interesting properties we're going to
talk about this all right so the first
benefit of oregano oil is its powerful
natural antibiotic properties the
antifungal antibacterial antiviral
antiparasite anti youth anti-candida so
it kills pathogens in your body without
killing your own microbes so it's really
really cool you just want to make sure
you take a little bit at a time to
gradually go into it because when you
kill some of these microbes they can
have like endotoxins within them which
actually can stir up an immune reaction
always go very very small like just take
one see how it goes and then you know if
you're fine maybe take two or three a
day for those people that have
antibiotic resistance this is the
solution and there's also some
interesting data on oregano oil
addressing biofilms and that's a whole
other topic for another video but
biofilms are microbes that hide in
little calcium shells and they're very
hard to get to so oregano oil with may
be a good key later to break up the
calcium would be a good remedy for that
so oregano is a very powerful
antioxidant to get rid of free radical
damage the complication from the
environmental oxidation and damage on
your DNA so oregano slows down that
process of oxidation alright three it's
a great antiseptic a lot of people mix
it with certain things to clean their a
house so it can actually sterilize
certain
in your environment it's good for acne
allergies very beneficial for allergies
and also you can see benefits for asthma
and lung issues in general bronchial
type stuff
now a lot of times bad breath can come
from a fungus or a microbe this is why
oregano oil is good for bad breath
bladder infections colds the flu which
is viruses sinus issues especially
chronic sinus from funguses it's all
year round
chances are it's a fungus among us okay
number eleven your infections you take a
drop of oregano oil and you can actually
put it in your ear and it's really good
for ear infections and children and
adults
mixing with garlic you'll smell like a
pizzeria but you will kill off that it
microbe all right we talked about the
bronchial thirteen hidden infections
like epstein-barr virus that goes into
remission and comes out of remission
when you're nutritionally deficient or
you're getting older or you're rundown
boom it comes out and you all of a
sudden you get chronic fatigue well this
is really good for that I'll give you
energy because it's actually can help
put this thing back in remission and
then we have SIBO small intestinal
bacterial overgrowth this is a situation
where the microbes that should be in the
large colon are now in the small
intestine and so when you eat food the
microbes basically steal the nutrition
and they ferment the fiber in the small
intestine and that creates a lot of
bloating so this is really good for this
condition you'd also want to add the
tain how to chloride outside a vinegar
and do fasting that would be very good
for that alright guys there you have it
the 14 benefits of oregano oil and check
out some of these other videos I have on
a regular oil there's a lot more to
learn on this